analysts and data scientists are often
dealing with data that's complex and not
ready for immediate analysis in fact
it's been almost 80% of their time
cleaning and preparing data accelerating
this process helps businesses be more
responsive with data-driven decisions
that's where Google Cloud Data prep
comes in data prep is an intelligent
data service for visually exploring
cleaning and preparing both structured
and unstructured data for analysis
it's a browser-based service and works
at any scale with no infrastructure to
deploy or manage in this lab you'll use
data prep to manipulate a dataset you
will import datasets correct mismatched
data transform data and join data if
this is all new to you you'll know what
all this means by the end of the lab and
it will only take you 45 minutes with
cloud data prep you can easily prepare
big data for things like training
machine learning models studying visual
analytics or for powerful interactive
queries that unlock insights from your
data this lab is part of the baseline
data ml and AI quests on quick labs
completing all the labs in this quest
earns you this badge to recognize your
new skills you can show off your badge
on your resume or social media channels
next on our quest Google Cloud Data Lab
QuickStart